John Smoltz major league baseball
Network John joining us part of Fox's
broadcast team calling the NLCS
beginning Saturday from Wrigley plus MLB
network's MLB tonight which airs before
and after every League Championship
Series John thanks for joining us this
morning how you feeling I'm uh I'm still
shaking my head I still can't believe
the four-game series that I was I had
the pleasure of calling I I knew is
going to be a good one had no idea it
was going to play out the way it did
what is the Cubs didn't win last night
it would have made probably for the most
watched Game five ever uh it would have
been a fantastic pitching matchup and a
lot of pressure on the Chicago Cubs and
forget the history that that is always
compounded pressures of of any
organization or team that hasn't been
part of something for a while this is
the best team in baseball that was going
to deal with their own pressure of
playing a pedigree unbelievable you know
just to stay with that theme can't lose
an elimination game team that's won
three championships I I thought it was
going to be probably the worst match up
for the Cubs before it started and it
could have been that scenario had it
played out and San Francisco got to a
game five yeah I'm right there with you
this was the team they didn't want to
face because the Giants understand how
to win but the Giants bull pen or lack
thereof came back and haunted them last
night you know they melted down in
dramatic fashion yeah they couldn't
avoid the inevitable and the inevitable
was something second half it just was a
problem for for Bruce Bochy and anybody
who thinks you know that this is the way
that the game has got to go and the mix
and match and throw as many pictures as
again you got to have a guy and that guy
has to be a lockdown guy that you trust
that you start the inning with every
single time the night then he comes
around if you don't have that guy this
is what inevitably can happen and undid
the San Francisco Giants in a way that I
never thought could happen in the ninth
inning momentum building series that was
really swinging towards the Giants if I
had a dress
right now of all the Chicago Cubs and
you have first pick who you takin gosh
that's a great question and and I would
have hands down it would have been
Bryant and it probably still could be
but the more you watch a Pedro Baez I
never thought he could make these
adjustments offensively this is a guy
that it had a historic strikeout rate
and it was almost like an automatic out
to any good pitcher that could face him
I never thought the defensive ability
that he has was this off the charts I
had heard it from Joe Maddon and and
it's absolutely right so you know
Brian's going to steal all the headlines
and rightfully so because he's got to
play multiple positions and the power
speaks for itself but the Cubs have put
themselves the reason it's a great
question to have so many choices and
that that's a that's a good thing if
you're trying to not only end a long
drought of World Series championships
but a fact that you can go deep and and
win a World Championship is why there
you know the favorite he said John
Smoltz major league baseball Network
joining us what do you expect in Game
five Dodgers Nationals is why you pay
Scherzer all that money for a moment
like this yeah and he's gonna love it
look he's become a whole different
person since he's come to nationally I
got a chance in Spring Training to just
you know get a sneak preview of his work
out his is effort of how he approaches
the game and it's not going to be short
of emotions not going to be short of of
you know all kinds of getting after it
and i think the Dodgers would much of
what you talked about about the San
Francisco Giants was which ended up
being their Achilles heel this has been
the Dodgers all year they're going to
have to face you know they're not to try
to throw six pitchers at them and see if
their bullpen can get it done it's a
tough scenario to keep having it be
successful but it has been that point
for the Dodgers that has allowed them to
get to this part and you know Rich Hill
Rich Hill is gonna have to be pretty
good and the leash is going to be short
and I'm sure Dave Roberts is going to
have all his guys lined up ready to go
similar to what Bruce Bochy did in the
World Series against Kansas
and I hope that blister situation
doesn't come back for hill before I let
you go youth baseball disciplining I
know you don't see discipline as much in
youth baseball we've been talking about
a football coach who got dismissed for
disciplining a kid he made him run uh
you got kids you experience this in a
part of it yourself uh you know then
we've gotten the balance of everything
in life's got not a whack you know there
are going to be some really bad ones and
there's some really good ones and I
think it's the the balance that we're
losing with with being able to
understand just the responsibility of
coaches and I love the thought of being
a coach the psychology of trying to get
kids to do things that they wouldn't do
on their own I love the challenge of
leading kids and and and that's that
mindset the pressure on coaches and the
self pressure to win to do things that's
when it gets out of balance and and I
think we you know we got to find a way
that just because somebody's unhappy or
the way something is is done that we
can't keep always giving that person or
persons power to make it you know the
way they want it to be it's not a
concierge style life that the sports
should or can be and kids cannot cannot
be the ones running the system kids
cannot hold all the all the answers at
the same time we've got to find a way to
weed out some that that are not very
good i I've followed my kids sporting
career as much as I kid through my own
and I've witnessed and i watch coaches
on the other side and there's only been
a couple times where I've gone up to the
person that's said you have no business
being in the coaching business you have
no business leading kids because the
idea that you have is not the idea of
what really coaching is about what kind
of a young kid but what were they doing
you know what's that what was the coach
doing the bothered you it was over the
top seven eight year old the gist just
trying to win so bad that it was it was
uh you could tell the frustration was on
he was living this frustration through
these days girls basketball situations
sometimes you looking to go come on and
and that's where
gets it gets a little crazy and uh you
know coaches good that they give of
their time if there was just a us an
opportunity that they could understand
three missions three goals three
scenarios arm that that would that help
better help them lead the bunch of kids
in a better way but it's it's it's not
9010 it's it's the you know bad it's the
ten percent that make it seem like going
on ninety percent just have to find a
better way to to weed those out good to
talk to you John have fun at Wrigley
Lula will be watching alright thanks
dance the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience